Two-way associations are trickier than one-way association.
One approach is to just duplicate the approach we had with one-way associations.
That is have your attribute in class A pointing to an instance in class B and
have in class B, an attribute which points to an instance in class A.
Or you could do these with,
with vectors if there's many, too many relationships.
You can use this approach if
if you don't run into referential integrity constraints.
If you have referential integrity constraints, you have to make sure, for
example, when you're deleting an element from a vector in instance of class A,
that you also go over and find the instance in class B.
And look in its vector to find the back pointer over to the instance in
class A and make sure that's deleted.
Puts an extra burden and complexity on your program.
An alternative to having a symmetric solution is to
just have pointers in one direction.
If you want to traverse in the other direction, you have to do a search.
So, let's say we'd like to go from an instance in class B
to an instance in class A.
First you have to find that instance in class B and
from it go back and find the instance in class A.
It's extra work.
And a third approach I want to mention is to use associations themselves
as objects.